The History of English in 10 minutes.
Chapter Four : The King James Bible or "let there be light" reading.
In 1611, the powers that be turned the world upside down...
...with a labor of love, a new translation of the bible.
A team of scribes with the wisdom of Solomon went the extra mile...
...to make King James's translation "all things to all men"...
...whether from their "heart's desire,"...
..."to fight the good fight" or just for the "filthy lucre."
This sexy new Bible "went from strength to strength" getting to the "root of the matter"...
...in a language even the "salt of the earth" could understand.
The "writing wasn't on the wall," it was in handy little books...
...with "fire and brimstone" preachers reading it in every church.
Its words and phrases took root to "the ends of the earth,"...
...or at least the ends of Britain.
The King James Bible is the book that taught us...
...that "a leopard can't change its spots,"...
...that "a bird in the hand is worth two in the bush,"...
...that "a wolf in sheep's clothing" is harder to spot than you would imagine,...
...and how annoying it is to have "a fly in your ointment."
In fact, just as Jonathan begat Meribbaal and Meribbaal begat Micah,...
...the King James Bible begat a whole glossary of metaphor...
...and morality that still shapes the way English is spoken today.
Amen.